[Music]
welcome back to careful boys everybody
we are currently off the record and we
have with us ron here so we're going to
be asking him a few questions based on
his expertise about fighting
i was like
which one
he's an expert in a lot yeah yeah we
could do some fighting chopsticks give
us your credentials on fighting so we
know you're legit before i ask you our
valuable questions yeah i don't want to
waste my questions on you yeah cause we
could be asking nick all the same [ __ ]
oh you want to ask ron about but nick
did the fighting too my training started
on yahoo.com it's a website search
engine did you really yeah no no i saw
ultimate fighter
back then and then i yahoo'd the nearest
mma gym and then i founded jiu jitsu
ultimately the tv show yeah the very
first one the very first season i was
like i want to do that
so i wanted to do it so bad that i
retired from my football career in high
school and so i did all three years and
my senior years like and i cried like
the whole team like they didn't cry
you were doing football yeah i played
football you're like a star quarterback
kind of nice uh i was junior and then my
star moment was i got to be special
teams in varsity
that was it so your coach was pretty sad
that you left yeah yeah because i was
just i was consistent there was a hard
worker i was tiny um and then like i
made the highlight video because i did a
cool play in a jv game and i made the
varsity video
i i tackled somebody and our helmets
came off and one of the guys headbutted
me with my helmet also went boom and
then i freaking got rocked was that your
first first concussion
my first concussion does that count as a
knockout in your record yeah oh and one
stay standing
trained there for seven years um ended
up finding uh timo yam and irvine stayed
there for another
so your first was jiu jitsu yeah oh jiu
jitsu and stanton yeah what made you
pick jiu jitsu specifically uh i typed
in mma gym and then de la jiu-jitsu
picked up i was like oh that sounds like
mma um and then so i went there well
back then there wasn't really mma gyms
it was just like hey learn jiu jitsu
learn some boxing and then right and
then fight like you gotta bounce around
do your own [ __ ] right application was
like up to you yeah i think it was like
super old school martial art style where
now we have like walmart super centers
of like mma you can do everything in
house
but yeah then i found a boxing gym did
that then i ended up doing everything
in-house at timoyama
fought i won an ifs championship in 2010
remember that the freaking ifs
international fight showdown was the
first champion
how soon did you win a championship
after starting uh
2010 i won it and i started in 2006.
ron just wins championships what's up
ifs is that striking only or mma
mma yeah it's uh it's popular in orange
county but uh when they started it was
at knott's berry farm that's pretty cool
at the theme park uh yeah what the theme
parks hotel the north very farm hotel
it's while they ride montezuma's revenge
ghost rider [ __ ]
in the freaking
coaster consider that amateur or is that
pro it was amateur
it was amateur and so i got a lot of
buzz doing that i got i ended up being
four and oh in my amateur career got
that what was funny is i won the belt
and they threw confetti everywhere we
didn't have a cannon but they threw it
at the tails manual confetti yeah but uh
the the guy that i beat ended up getting
a trophy that was way clearer than the
belt the trophy was like six feet high
it was dope but he got to keep the
trophy i got the belt i was like
i kind of want to trade your trophy
and did you knock out my friend chris
farhado my training partner
who's your trading partner here's my
training partner ron never tried to
avenge him not he knocked him out one
time in amateurs and then you knocked
him out one time in pro he's nice he's a
sweetheart he kind of reminds me of ron
really yeah in a lot of ways he's a
really sweet guy
but he knocks people out he's really
tough and durable kind of just like ron
but you didn't feel like avenging your
friend and fighting ron dude definitely
not
definitely not i fought him during that
tournament the ifs tournament so was it
eight oh yeah he was in there are you
guys the same weight class or not uh you
fi you fought 135 right yeah 25 and 35.
yeah so my ammun try 35 but if ron's in
my division i'll go up he's like i'm out
i'll
which that was the fight where you
elbowed some guy like seven thousand
times right that's my boy dude
that's your boy seven thousand times was
it really a lot like well because like
our buddy chris he was known for having
in the gym
oh i don't know he was chris i'm sorry i
love you
you got to watch this fight dude ron
literally literally i think like 30
times i used to train we used to train
with christmas 17. chris was he was
known for having one of the toughest
chins and he would [ __ ] everybody up
like he would [ __ ] rip up in the gym
like i've i've kicked this fool in the
head and he just goes ah nice and i'm
like oh sick you know like and that
usually dick yes
but he just was crazy like you're not
really selling this guy he couldn't get
knocked out this guy and then for him to
get knocked down to fight the way he did
at that time we were all like oh oh you
were there no we just saw we just heard
about it afterwards but it was you know
it was a long time ago the first time
was freaking crazy because uh we did
homework on him we knew he was crazy and
wild and whatnot so the first time he
fought like in 2010 they're like hey
don't engage with him let him circle
circle circle when he engages then do
your thing and then 30 seconds half it
was my first 30 second knockout um we
were circling circling circling he threw
a head kick i blocked it threw an
overhand and he freaking went down like
he went knee face plant and then i feel
horrible because he had a seizure
oh yeah i was scared yeah it was my it
was the first time i ever did that to
anybody so i was like oh shoot
and then and then like it wasn't really
a victory i could enjoy because he was
freaking hurt you know yeah um so i was
in the camo days right the rash guards
they first started i was the reason why
they took knees away from the face so in
the amateur days they let you kneed to
the head
in the beginning they let you kneed to
the freaking head as an amateur that was
probably one of the first years they
actually started the organization right
yeah
because i remember that was like one of
the first things ever like that was one
of the first events that's gangster
that's some [ __ ] pride rules [ __ ]
yeah they left the knee to the head and
then the gloves were even worse because
they were six ounce gloves now they're
eight or something that's like that's
like paper the bad part about so uh pro
is four ounces but they're light but the
six ounces were
just were worse because they were
heavier so now i have the hardness of no
padding but the freaking weight of eight
ounces behind my punch and it really
hurts those gloves are really [ __ ]
hard those gloves freaking hurt i'd
rather get hit with pro gloves than
those amateur gloves yeah they they're
really dead okay that's the first whack
question
how do you balance like because you're
such a nice guy how do you balance the
compassion with the absolute like bee
sting it's a it's an on off switch
so it's weird i'll uh i'm friendly up
until the
ring thing
the the ring bell and then i get this
weird tunnel vision and all i hear is my
corner like the crowd mutes everybody
mutes and then it's just complete focus
she's like okay here we go game plan
game plan game plan game plan and then
all of a sudden like uh either i wake up
from my unconsciousness
because i got knocked out
or i was there for that one
uh or i freaking have a breath like pull
me off and then i get i i might i knock
out of my tunnel vision
like it's like quiet you know also
ah i hear like cheering everywhere i'm
like oh snap yeah it's almost like what
about in in training there's no ref or
rings and stuff like are you in tunnel
of it do you have to turn it on in
training mm-hmm and training i'm
laughing the whole time like i'm i'm
having fun so you're not fighter wrong
in training your regular run
yeah but then in in the ring that's like
fighter on turns on yeah bad intentions
yeah bad intentions i never hit that
hard during training ever when did you
when did you
snap into like fighter on like because
like when you're first training and all
that right did you ever
understand or feel that or was it your
first real fight
yeah it took like probably like seven
eight years for me to get like
comfortable to do it otherwise in the
beginning it was fight or wrong i didn't
have any skills but i try to kill people
and people try to kill me it just feels
like surprise white boy well white belt
rage it's very old school just
yeah there was even in training it was a
hundred percent yeah back in the day
when i first started training like we
were just trying to kill each other but
like yes that was the culture for real
it was back in the day forever not even
just me it was just the thing to do all
the training was that when me and bart
started mma that's how we thought that
was normal yeah it was and it was yeah
everyone went hard first sparring
and like let's say me and him are just
doing light touches or whatever our
sensei would be like you step out and he
would just beat the [ __ ] out of one of
us
like he was just but you guys are going
way too light and he would just come in
and [ __ ] us up yeah that was the culture
yeah definitely the culture and then so
we just knew oh [ __ ] sensei's walking
around we better step it up kind of hard
and then like when he walks away to that
side okay bring it back down
and our old buddy that we trained with
from the same gym we brought him with
nick and and nick [ __ ] his ass up and
then and then and he's all like yeah but
i was a man though because i didn't back
down i stood there and took it i'm like
yeah he had zero head movement though
it's like you're supposed to dodge hook
it
but did i die i took those hits like a
man the game is to hit and not get hit
not get hit get hit get it
that's new school
that's that new [ __ ] yeah you just wait
style yeah with like science and
everything going on like now like we do
we don't even start like when i first
joined timo yama my my leg was black and
blue for three months because i didn't
know how to defend a kick
but now circa like 10 years later like
we're going like 30 40 like sometimes 70
percent and that's it but no one's
trying to rip each other's heads off
anymore so it's really interesting how
training is trained today's video is
brought to you by feels cbd is not about
what you feel it's about what you do not
feel such as stress pain anxiety and for
me i've been incorporating cbd into my
meditation sessions because in the
morning sometimes i am hit with
excruciating anxiety and i'm just like
what the [ __ ] man
right when i wake up as a lion's chasing
me there's no tigers here i'm not in the
jungle and i'm just like man i need to
calm my nerves so i have a cbd ritual
where i go drippity drop drop drop and
then i do my breathing exercises and i
just chill and meditate and i start the
day in a good kind of tone and i used to
do this as a nighttime routine but now
it is a good morning routine that's dope
if you don't know what fields is it's
premium cbd subscription delivered right
to your door and if it's your first time
you might be like oh i don't know what
to do well you're in luck because they
got a hotline that will walk you through
the whole thing you'll hold your hand do
i take a little do i take a lot should i
make it with tea the way joe does or
should i just put under my tongue
they'll walk you through the whole thing
and it's amazing and it comes in a
discreet little box that comes to your
door monthly so you don't have to worry
because it's a subscription so start
feeling better with feels become a
member today by going to feels.com
off the record and you'll get 50 off
your first order with free shipping
that's f e a l s dot com off the record
to become a member and to get 50
automatically taken off your first order
plus free shipping fields.com
off the record here's another question
um you having this
super power how do you resist not using
it on the streets
like if someone talks [ __ ] to you
because you know you could just lay
someone out right how do you like like
let's say someone's rude to your girl or
like you know someone you could tell
someone tries to punk you a little bit
how do you just not like you know it's
time to go zero to a thousand real quick
damn control uh
lots and lots of control it's a point of
control
let it go uh
i fight enough in the gym and in the
ring where fighting outside just doesn't
it doesn't it's not fulfilling it
doesn't do any i already know that it
brings nothing but trouble um so if it
ever gets never gotten to that point no
one's ever tried you like i mean when i
was doing personal security and bouncing
and stuff like that like i got to
message people then that was fun don't
they go like like in the security
setting they'd be like oh that little
dude oh all the time i was the first i
would always every time i went to a new
bar or a club i was the everybody would
push the limits like hey let's get let's
see we can get away with you know from
people spitting in my face throwing hats
on my face just freaking pouring jinx in
like what do you do what do you do i
subdue them how do you do that what's
your move to subdue somebody do this in
that setting
um
i can either just type
or freaking i can just do a uh like
like a vice grip no i just drag them
that usually works most of the time yeah
or i can bear hug them dude dude normal
people have no idea how to get a bear
hug i'll literally just go behind here
i'm like come on it's time to go and
i'll pick him up why don't you get out
of this i'll walk up out
hug
that's a fine happy birthday yeah you're
leaving this club
okay okay i'll leave i'll leave
i want to make love that it works
that'll work
i always do a three a three a three
warning world's like look i gotta tell
you a third time i'm gonna have to
forcibly get you out of here and usually
i talk pretty calm and they're like huh
okay and then so the most you've ever
had to do is just one of those so dude i
power i suplexed somebody once that was
bad i thought i was gonna go to jail
it was another guy he was allegedly
how'd you do it allegedly yeah allegedly
oh no this is good because i i didn't
get in trouble for it oh
yeah yeah it was this really tall dude
the problem with tall guys are
everything they do is exaggerated right
undercenter of gravity is higher and
their dick is just right here if i do
this it's not a big deal but if a big
tall guy does it he's like freaking like
an octopus with tentacles so we're in
this uh this orange county bar that i
was working at and this guy is just
drunk having a good time in the middle
of the dance floor but he's just waving
and as he waves over he's smacking his
head
as he's dancing and he's not doing it on
purpose no not on purpose he's just he's
right he's true oh he's just he's having
a good time so go back hey man like you
got to calm down like you're like
whacking people in the back of the head
like i'm like there's other people here
trying a good time too he's like all
right all right i leave he like he
chills out he looks around he starts to
do it again pop pop pop pop and like
girls and godzilla do it and nobody
wants to cause trouble you know
what the heck
yeah we can jerk i go back and it's like
dude this is the second time if i have
to tell you again freaking i'm going to
have to escort you cause he's looking
so high
i put my hand on my eye man thank you
and then i look away and he goes
he kicks my hand off yeah i'm like oh
heck no no so i freaking bear hug him
and then i'm trying to keep him still
and he like gets tall so i start getting
off the ground because i'm shorter than
him and so i sit down and i and then a
point of kind of anger gets not angered
but like oh [ __ ] it's happening and then
so i freaking pick him up over and i'm
here and then i turn around and boom
and then like he's standing here and
he's knocked out he's out he's like
freaking exorcism like freaking contours
yeah you slammed him good yeah it was
bad and the ground was uh turf with
concrete on the bottom it was like a
rooftop topless bar thing oh and like
adrenaline like i'm pumping and this is
like within seconds when i was like
dude and i snapped out i was like oh no
what did i do he broke your bruce lee
necklace the little ring
i promise
and i look around and like people look
like i just killed somebody i see a girl
like remember
oh my god i did you super shirt right
no witnesses
this is a lot to me what one junk person
jumps right next to him he goes one two
three he's out world champion they put
the belt on you and i'm like dude so i i
picked this guy started check out him
the place is crowded so like i got guys
in the front guys in the back but i'm in
charge of the dance floor so like i'm
like fudge what do i do i pick this guy
up and i put him over my shoulders and
he's so tall his hands and feet are
dragging on the floor you could carry
this guy so i'm counting obviously
wasn't that easy he had a leg
but um i dragged him out to the patio
and i'm like he's out i'm like and i'm
this is my first time dude i'm freaking
out hey dude like look freaking this is
what happened and i explained what
happened it's like
it was either that or he freaking picked
me off the ground and threw me man like
i didn't mean a suplex and he's just
freaking he's huge he jumped he jumped
into my arms dude i'm i'm nervous dude
because at this back in the day you
could do whatever you want security like
you could beat people up in your quote
but now you get sued left and right
super suit yeah yeah that and we were in
the suing era
was hot at that moment and then these
two guys like run into the paddock
because we closed out the paddy like we
know him we know him we know him he's
like oh my gosh are you okay are you
okay i'm like i'm so much i'm in trouble
i'm going to jail tonight because you
can go to jail for this for sure so you
go to jail they look at me and then it's
like a lull and they're like
we are so sorry it's like this will
never happen again i'm like
that's right it won't because you guys
aren't allowed back get out of here
right now get out of here get a taxi cab
and go do it we're so sorry they're
dragging him and then dragging the taxi
cab it won't happen again sir i'm sorry
i'm like get out of here and then they
get off and then they leave them like
whoa
i'm like did you just get out of trouble
allegedly
theoretically
hypothetically
yeah yeah yeah that didn't happen that's
a cool made-up story you came up with on
the spot you're really good at improv
man it was actually in riverside
[Laughter]
riverside
uh atlanta when did you get over your
fear of uh
getting into confrontations fighting
with people because there's i think
everyone like before they get into a
fight there is that like what if and
it's scary right but then afterwards it
becomes this weird
not you get over the fear it's still
scary but then there's this weird
calmness to it it's weird in the i get
i'll get more not that i get in street
fights a lot but confrontations i'll get
more adrenaline in a confrontation with
a regular person than stepping in the
ring and fighting because i'm i'm i'm
finding that environments no i'm used to
it but this is a random person that i
wasn't in the right mindset to fight
right i'm just chilling like yeah just
having a sense we could have a weapon
yeah i'm just having a sandwich that's
good mother after what i'm like
huh you know what what did i do you know
at first it's a joke but as soon as like
i feel like
dude i'm like oh crap this is crap
actually because most people don't do
anything what do you do when you start
feeling that like uh oh oh really then
then i'm gonna fly if my heart's pumping
i'm like then i'm i have a spider sense
i'm sensing danger so i'm like okay
let's put the sandwich down but as a
security
there's always danger right
or like there's always confrontation not
always but i'm always scouting the area
like i took my job very seriously so i'd
and i got that with being in just public
spaces and i teach that during my
self-defense training classes uh for
like the elderly people that i work with
because you're trying to stop the asian
haters that's why they're editing people
are all suplexing everybody yeah
that's me
that's me
are now going like this
[Laughter]
you recently did the whole asian asian
hate [ __ ] right for the seniors yeah i'm
still doing that watching the grandma
how often do you do that yeah
it was once a month but i don't know
what happened we picked up a lot we're
doing like we're doing like two three
events a month it's crazy wow yeah they
uh we won non-profit uh of the year in
sacramento so i have to fly to
sacramento and they want to give like an
award thingy
and then i gotta say gavin newsom's like
can you suplex me show me
at my vineyard
no no it's it's been open you're good
that's how you crush the grapes
there's two places we don't stop them
around here yeah suplex though
that's why they can tell trust me
i can taste the paint
oh
has there ever been a moment where
you're like
i don't want to fight anymore like it
doesn't bring me any happiness or like
what am i doing like you just want to
quit that life yeah lots of moments you
have lots of lots of downs especially
after every time i lose because i i've
dedicated my whole life to fighting
getting into ufc being ufc champion and
still not in the ufc still not a ufc
champion so every loss that i had
brought me back every fight that i lost
was supposed to get me
into the ufc yeah and every time i lost
it freaking took me down like when you
saw me get knocked out i got invited to
trainer demetrius uh johnson at his gym
and like if ufc was an option they were
going to help me get a one i lost that
one um and then demetrius johnson was
like you can't train here no more he
didn't tell me directly but my manager
was like yeah he kind of lost your shot
i was like oh
whoa yeah
do you cry like do you cry by yourself
or with their wife when [ __ ] like that
stuff happens or very rarely sometimes
sometimes because life is hard right
everybody's struggling and uh there's a
few moments yeah there's hard moments
like i had some hormones and fighting i
was like fudge man dedicated my whole
life to this and freaking you know i had
so many detours along the way you know
like i wasn't supposed to run a gym i
wasn't supposed to like do personal
trainers supposed to just fight i look
at all my teammates and they dedicate
their lives and now they're top
contenders in the world i was like fudge
you know i love my life but i definitely
could have chosen a bunch of different
routes you know like is this for me like
do i want to do this like i'm i'm barely
getting by i love what i do but
you know do i want something else do i
want something more i don't know
like yeah it's tough when you have a
goal or a dream and you're almost there
and then you don't reach it and then so
do you like do i keep going for this
dream or do i find
other dreams now you know that's gonna
wrap that up currently
finding weather dreams
[Laughter]
not on camera
not on camera
she's like okay
[Laughter]
now that layer one is off
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you